thank you to both rocket money and hellofresh
for sponsoring this video more on them after
the reaction [Music] people citizens of the
reject Nation it is time for Monarch episode
6 today John how are you I'm good I'm ready
to love this one G that's what I like to hear
guys what did you think about this episode if
you're watching this video you've already seen
it leave your thoughts down below how's
Monarch been for you overall ladies and
gentlemen you know what to do go ahead leave
a like that'd be very much appreciated also
subscribe click that notification Bell to get
notifi when our next reaction from Monarch is
up here on this Chanel thank you to prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights and thank
you to all of you who have followed us over at
our patreon page over there you get the full
length ratch and watch along that's where
you sync up with your own copy of Monarch
and also John and I Rec cover several shows
over there exclusively with highlights and
watch alongs included John you ready to get into
this so ready let's do this let's do it [Music]
ah yes the past what did I tell
you I'm going to love this a yes
oh my God that Blazer all these Caucasians
hey they must have banged at one point AA they do
look lovely the both of them doctor I'm supposed
to wear this no no no no you're supposed to eat
it I thought you might be hungry so I picked
you up some along the way that's racist is it
racist yeah maybe I don't know okay or is she
being sweet I don't know I'm expected to impress
man who can't remember my name and would just as
soon shut us down as turnu Weaponry why isn't
really here fair just koperate you're lucky to
be here at all say hello say say thank you to
the people who are footing the bill and now we
can go on our merry way exhale smile fall in
love with me yes captain Lee Shaw when he was
respected up him out of a a bar brawl it's all
busted up are you drunk yeah he's alliterating
like mad do you remember what I told you to
do to succeed in this man's Army remember
when we were alone in your office only punch
Sailors and Marines from now on and the crowd
[Music] laugh ah you got me Dr K Mira thank
you Captain Europe Japanese name yeah hey
she's one of the good ones whoa what do
you mean whoo you said she's one of the
good ones yeah so and so is he so is Chris
H doll of course one of the good ones it's a
compliment you're one of the good women and
one of the good Japanese people guys like
them they are oldfashioned if we ever find
another Titan those oldfashioned men will
blow it up or March it into Red Square yeah
that's the truth now you're going to change
their minds in as oldfashioned as they may
be no cuz it's what you do you did it to
me you are a force of nature you haven't
seen anything yet you are the Titan of my
heart everyone is looking at us they're all
thinking the same thing he's dancing
with one of the good Japanese women
yes now do some kind of like big show
stop and swing number get the whole
room looking at you then you'll secure all the
funding and maybe some karate with a samurai
[Music] sword and that was the
moment he decided to shun away
Lea
oh that's the best
moment
oh he was attracted to her too I
mean this romance is nothing like
kiry Clemens and canara yeah can we get
back to the real Beating Heart of the show
please a that was so lovely you could be one
of them being career military might not be so
bad more nights like this a life like this you
can be controlled even more a house neighbors
Barbecues in the backyard kids kids bring it
back to episode one kid oh they they heard
you
oh the pinkies do you know what my favorite thing
about children is never afraid to say I don't know
everything every day is an adventure and a mystery
that's was pretty know at all child want don't
know what my favorite thing about children is you
can hit them with a belt making them learn them
good I think they're foreshadowing them having
maybe children urgent message for captain Lee
Shaw from Bill random oh maybe next L Soldier
oh no freaking Bill Randa he knew what he was
doing see all just got a approach this
with a beginner's [Music] mind they did
the secret knock change [Music]
your that's [Music] clever oh
yeah that was cool that was pretty
cool that's pretty sweet clean ooh
cleaner my nuts the things I cut for mon but I
got a good idea about what's going on didn't do
enough about that when I had the chance figure on
making up for that now you're here they've known
everything for years I've been telling them for
years and they keep ignoring what tell me what
tell me why tell us we'll believe you why not
because I'm crazy just like Wild Bill Randa and
his crazy kid hero how anyone who disagrees with
him is got to be just crazy crazy Wild Bill uh-oh
what about you mamelle hand is shaking doubt the
system my sister Sandra she worked in Japan some
of us came to Monarch saying never again I meant
it oh and there're more who feel like me waiting
for someone to show home you need to Blink you
won't be crying if you just you know hydrate your
eyes does that make me crazy I think you and
I have a lot to talk about yeah you guys got
a lot to inform the audience about this is like
that 2014 Godzilla movie except instead of like
only getting fleeting glimpses of Godzilla
it's fleeting glimpses of any kind of the
answer sorry for interrupting your big whatever
the hell it was I don't give a [__] but I think
we got a live one my man a guy thinks he saw it
but isn't sure what kind of a data are we sorry
oh the only other time I've seen isotopic
signatures like this was in the Philippines
uhoh poo Pride this is a Titan it's not
definitively not a Titan okay that's
definitively not an answer what is it three
most beautiful words in the English language I
don't know mindset children yes we divide and
conquer you stay and deal with the hardware
storm no no no I'm not letting you go on a
Titan hunt alone well who can we leave behind
or you both of you either you know what I
mean sheepers but we need to prove Titans
exist to get money for the good of Monarch
something's got to give oh boy rocking a hard
place Jack Nichols it's in the middle of the
Sahara woo woohoo Let's go Team how are we even
going to get there get where Mom [__] Colonel
hey what's she doing here well Michelle's dancing
on the side of the Angels now I don't know we can
use her help something's coming gday * 100 G I
think your father's trying to stop what's coming
and I got a pretty good idea how he's going to
do it only way to know for sure is to find him
m- she tried kidnapping me what are we talking
about we're going to the hollow Earth on Monarch's
orders but she's not taking orders from Monarch
anymore because she's with us and you can trust
her and I'm going to say all that for her she's
our ride now all we need is a destination which
is of course where you come in get your Maps boy
I mean the only other incident that happened would
be the Godzilla versus Comm that Godzilla I guess
Hoshi he he RS the office with the million dooll
view right but he sits with his back to it why so
he can stare how whatever was here oh good call
yes like an office you're like Sherlock Holmes
dude [Music] yeah
the mystery intensifies this pattern it's
familiar right these holes what how would
you really would you really put this her what
did roshi do to get exiled from Monarch his file
sealed he wasn't exiled misuse of government
assets government Maps he kept retargeting
deep space satellites to look at things they
weren't supposed to like what like Earth well
what do they normally look at space deep space
far away [__] you know that you can you know
that electromagnetic spectrum Cosmic radiation
gamas oh and these files become Monarch these
are all places Monarch has or ever had boots
on the ground you got all that from the holes
there's got to be a reason this guy has a job at
Monarch let him cook I I'll give him the benefit
of the doubt for now it's leading to answers
at least if we pull the data on where Hiroshi
was redirecting the satellites we will get a
perfect match Godzilla emerges west of Hawaii
at this cluster heads towards the mainland gamma
race bike right oh swims West another Spike but
Hiroshi flew North to this cluster another
gamma race bike where we found Shaw his kids
and that new Titan oh so they're looking for
their father dad's boy it looks like Hiroshi
recorded three more Gam surges here in Central
Asia and what would that be Vietnam Cambodia and
here uh-oh I can't get over the fact he saw
very vague holes on that and was like don't
these holes look familiar well you know he was
like here's a pin and maybe this used to be a
corkboard I'll I I'll give it to him but I get you
I'm teetering on the edge remarkably fast you know
oh my God he's wearing his classic outfit hey that
eventually he'll fill out yep it's a very flexible
out is this who I think it is
oh I don't think it is is it you never [Music]
know Monster Island whatever out generate
radiation at Cosmic levels so I constructed
that a g radiation simulator whoa the more
signals I simulate the more radiation whatever
is out there generates in no Sara will be like
100 by the time yeah but maybe he's got that LE
[__] that that he's got he's 90 doesn't look
it we're in the right
[Laughter] place they always look fresh off the
rack this wasn't part of our deal when do I get to
go home the sunglasses I'll keep my word yeah when
as soon as we make it out of the desert the desert
that we shot this scene in good seeing you Scotty
I don't want anything to do with an arm Aron X
monar goon all the apples in the Monarch Barrel
aren't bad Kate uh-oh the colonel is starting a
movement we're not here to start a movement okay
it's a trap all right this is where you want off
just understand understand that consequences
will be on your heads now too what consequences
thousands maybe millions of lives lost that your
grandparents and father were trying to save that's
why he had two families yes in order to save more
lives if you want to bail we can bail I wanted to
call it a day in Alaska someone setting that up
in pistan hat the only way out is thr boom skip
has anything they have to say no we had to call
back to a few episodes ago when they bonded that
one time please skip thanks for your help oh he
knows he knows the dial of Destiny our comedies
exactly what kind of fish are we talking about
here Billy a big one wish you were here pal no
he loves you too you know I don't recall receiving
your RSVP for my family cookout Captain General I
request a hot dog with extra ketchup sir my people
are in the field and they need me sir no we have
men for that lead call them the Army not the Army
sir just me I see great things in your future Le
you got to sit at the grown-ups table if you want
them it's called building a career oh Monarch is
my career sir then stop treating it like a job
damn there are generals and there are soldiers
I understand that sir you could have fooled me now
you have a choice to make and I trust you to make
it the 50 scenes are just so much better it's
so much more simple wholesome I'm sure this is
the spot on the map what that means exactly only
your dad can tell us I think it's just over this
Ridge let's go come on
[Music] team I don't know where she's just
going to blur it out I had a gay Affair yes
I feel real guilty about it I'm sorry you
could have just called it an affair yeah
it doesn't matter really the emotional
damage is the same see there is that
Dad oh my god oh and he's got a modified version
of the thing oh man how great would it be if he
just died right before their eyes right now
is just dropped out of a heart attack yeah oh
no oh I think some's going to come kill
him right now he going die he's calling
something saying get away yeah he's
waving him [Music] off ooh this is
intense [Laughter] oh oh [__] go oh wait
this is a flashback they've gone fishing
spooky good shot have you ever
seen one or Saturn a Titan yes
we have greatest day of my life
great now he's in love other yes
everyone bars not every Asian actor
who's enthusiastic is heu Kuan John
shut up I'm sorry they're just all key to
me Lee didn't think you were going to make
the party deck him Lee I'm taking you girl
he made a a GMA radiation simulator that
actually simulates um you know the only
thing worse than being a third wheel being a
fourth let's walk whoa getting that clearing
the way you see like he stopped caring about
the actual Mission and too much about her she
had to push him away yeah breaks my heart
and randa's just married to his Titans you
know I think he's waving us off what's
going on no no [Music] no oh oh no this
poor guy maybe he was just dodging the awkward
confrontation between his two children I don't
want talking about my two families go it's
a weird time in my life oo oh good oh good
first an ice Kaiju now a desert kaijou
yeah one for every climate you weren't
supposed to come my place is here with you
you need what love your job is to protect
Monarch without you there is no Monarch found a
good way to justify spending time with her nice
friend you know we can't do this we can try
how long before I NE of us makes a decision
based on what we want instead of what mon
needs pretty soon so Bill Randy just got in
like at one point was like you know what I'm
going to dat yeah I guess we can't put the
greater good before our own desires the great
are good risk losing everything I don't care
I put my desires before all great are good
oh damn she's pregnant let's go yes you do
[Music] oh here come what the device your
love your love attracted to Titan where
is it it's been swallowed what an interesting lens
oh take it
back oh sh [__] oh it's Godzilla I had know
those dorsal KS anywhere whoa nice he's alive oh
yeah I hope you brought enough for
everyone oh yeah Jesus Christ we
didn't kill it a she's so happy thank
God oh here we go history is repeating
itself what were you doing out there
hero
oh is it Gods again or is it like rock Godzilla oh
dirt Zilla yeah so we just like hibernating here
yeah I guess so getting all toasty warming
its blood up wao wow everyone will survive
this oh oh no canaro my man [Music]
dude oh [__] wow right face your
trauma jeez that's scary that is
scary waking up just roll R over in
bed I love
it oh that's
scary the one they've all feared the
king oh King
Titan yeah what is the pilot doing right now
oh [__] oh no you harm one hair on hell
yeah yeah look at that M cut the
commercial ear pods and that's the last we see
of Godzilla he saw me yeah he did dude you got
to connection got a psychic Bond he knows about
your gay Affair and he thinks you should just call
it an affair so we can't keep that to ourselves
so we tell them and then what they build an even
bigger weapon and try again and if that doesn't
work an even bigger one and if they can't find
Goda maybe then they'll find somebody else to
use it on yeah buddy well we need to protect
ourselves okay and I certainly wasn't supposed
to come back empty-handed so I need something
I can put in front of pocket so so we can get
our asses out of the dogghouse how about some
eggs I'll try and go sell this to Pucket uh-oh
you've been infiltrated just going over some of
your field reports uh what's going on in the Navy
we call it a change of command in the Navy you can
take over an operation I'll expect a full report
and accounting of your little field trip on my
desk my end of day what you done made the wrong
choice bucko did you find anyone no one survived
the crash and we're running out of time got her
makeup still looks great yeah man so we Chase
Godzilla then what more people die we can't stop
him Jesus Kate I'm trying to help him hey if you
come with me you'll know everything I promise
you no thank God the only place we're going is
after our father Kate just go with him I want to
know what the hell he's been talking about this
whole show and it'll probably lead to your father
anyway civilization is just 10 clicks that way you
go now you'll be there long before dinner alons
Al Doctor Who fan over here he's probably seen
it through every iteration yeah he's old enough
that's how he's alive regeneration maybe he was
running from Godzilla or trying to lure him you
know away from us we know he made it the farar and
so did we he's alive so we keep looking all right
oh I can't do this anymore oh my god this is my
fault what do you mean seriously no I sold you out
did you a couple of years ago I pissed some people
off until I had to run and I ran to Japan uh-huh
until Monarch figured me out when they picked us
up and they left the deal on the table and they
said that if I told them where we were I could
go home and I could get my life back and I could
be with my family a the only way I is through F I
have money I don't want your godamn money listen I
have a lot of money I can get us wherever you want
want to go go to help well I don't have that much
money Kate I'm [Music] sorry but the both of you
I whatever Kate come back come back Kate we Bond
it in Alaska Kate don't don't walk over there Kate
Kate don't Kate you're walking you know don't
walk to the third click I can see you for Miles
Kate jeez you know what I'll say what's that
say it I'll say that with all that money she
has a great way to manage that yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's hear about it would be with um some
fuel oh yeah into your rocket ship oh take
you into the cosmos of M I'm transitioning
stop talking about gay Affairs hey reject Nation
you know running real rejects is an incredible
journey something I am truly grateful for but
I got to be real with you for one second here
managing the business side especially taxes to
put it lightly is incredibly overwhelming it's
like navigating a maze without a map and that's
where our sponsor rocket money comes in a sponsor
when approached I was so excited to work with
because I kid you not just last month I started
using rocket money cuz I needed to sort out this
financial puzzle and honestly it's been quite eye
openening not just for taxes but boy oh boy that
whole cliche of this app is true I discovered apps
and subscriptions I have been paying for that
I had not used in ages it is like finding out
you've been leaving lights on in a room that you
never use so yes rocket money isn't just another
app it's like a freaking Financial Guardian Angel
if finds and cancels those forgotten subscriptions
monitors your spending and even battles to lower
your bills thank God it's as if they're personally
invested in saving your hard-earned money like
I try I really try to be on top of my expenses
but rocket money they show me blind spots with a
simple tab I can cancel unnecessary subscriptions
they even handle the hassle of negotiating with
customer services a relief my goodness to put it
into perspective rocket money has helped over
5 million users save an average of $720 a year
that's more than just numbers it's a piece of
mine so if I invite you my fellow Rejects and
taking control of your finances so go ahead visit
rocket money.com rejects once again that's rocket
money.com rejects let's save together rocket.com
re I really do stand by this app thank you for
partnering with us as many of you guys know most
of my days are a couple of hours of filming and
then most of the time it's dedicated to like
editing and a bunch of other computer work
often accumulating to like 10 to 12 hours a
day and on top of that comfort food is like
my life's biggest Vice but as many of you also
know working out and getting healthier has been
a massive component for me this year in particular
so in this Whirlwind I have found myself a perfect
Ally for quick healthy meals America's number
one meal kit a meal kit that I have subscribed
to prior to ever agreeing and working with them
so yes this is a genuine testimony and that is
of course for hello fresh and hellofresh isn't
just about ease about bringing health and flavor
to your doorstep in this holiday season forget
about the stress of planning meals for your health
conscious friends friends like me who will breathe
down the back of your neck being like I can't eat
that that's unhealthy so with hello fresh I'm
looking forward to hosting holiday dinners that
are not only delicious but also cater to Healthy
Lifestyles best part the variety it is incredible
I'm p V Arian so they have these delicious meals
just like dejon onion crunch salmon over lemon
broccoli spaghetti and for one more plant-based
days the vegan Maple carrot power bowls they
aren't just meals they're culinary Adventures I
learned the word culinary during a long day the
last thing I want to do is spend a while cooking
and that's where helloof Fresh's 15minute meals
are a lifesaver they're quick nutritious and Oho
tasty perfect for my non-stop lifestyle so why
not join me in making this holiday season both
health conscious and delicious with hellofresh
with over 45 recipes and seasonal add-ons to
choose from every week there's always something
new to try and here's something to cheer about go
to hellofresh.com reject free and use code reject
free for free breakfast for life is that accurate
that sounds way too good to be true there's no
way that can be true go to hellofresh.com reject
free and use code reject free for free breakfast
for Life One breakfast item per box as long as
your subscription is active tag your hellofresh
creations with # hellofresh pick and at hello
fresh and let's cook up some fun and healthiness
reject Nation remember it's America's number
one meal kit well that was possibly the best
episode they've done so far in my personal and
objective opinion agree John what did you think
I got exactly what I was hoping for I loved it
I loved it so much no it was all right I liked
it it was good it was the best one so far it
had some things that I tend to not love love
about the show still in effect however had a lot
more balance of things that made me enjoy both
timelines to varying degrees uh so yeah I I would
say while still not like loving it the way I maybe
want to be this was a much more positive and fun
experience than some of the previous episodes did
Apple just like run out of money with Godzilla
I'm very fascinated to know if that's the case
whenever I I thought like oh [__] looks like
we're going to get like a real Godzilla episode
all of a sudden oh he's gone there There He Go we
got this this one good few shots of a sequin he
just he just walked away yeah yeah he just like
walked out he just walked away disappeared like
what did you get do could keep up with him did you
burrow underneath a mountain already without any
seismic activity this is the run that we see in
Godzilla xcon he learned how to do it right there
he learned how to do the Batman vanish like [__]
god wow stealthy guy that's why he's the kid oh
don't worry we'll find our dad oh he's he's just
gone just freaking gone there's no tire tracks he
can't see a distant vanan anywhere of a [__]
that his old friend was back that his daughter
and his son were there didn't give a [__] about
any of that yeah that felt about in line with how
everything in The Show Goes get the hell out of
here got to find her dad no get out of here got
to find her dead get leave there's a reason I
want to be around you guys um but yeah no it
the 50 storyline is of the origins of Monarch uh
is progressively the one most intriguing element
in terms of like an actual story yeah to me at
least agree the other stuff kind of fluctuates
between interesting to just give me something
to chew on a little bit please and to oh my God
I feel like they sometimes it just thinks they're
telling us new information take the Columbo scene
we kind of knew all that sure right like for the
most part we just need to check in it was maybe
like one or two sentences we did not know but
for the most part we knew all that but the way
they reveal it and spend time there it kind of
makes you think wow we got no we didn't we knew
all that yeah because it only brought us as far
as our main protagonists get yeah then they just
show up to get hit by the Godzilla um fin yeah and
then they disappear so that he can that Tim can
come back next episode with like a horrific scar
on his face yeah and a darker tone I am Kobo I'm
now Robo I'm Alex Murphy okay Dr Tim Doom yeah um
disappearing but the stuff in Monarch in the 50s
origin like that stuff is really tense and taut
and and there's there the even even like the the
RO that that is the star everything they attempt
to do in the present day and they apply since it
is like a mirror effect in history repeating
itself and then present day resolving things
from the past every type of Mystery Box intriguing
element character-driven narrative that they try
to do uh which is the reflection in a lot of ways
of the past the past is where it's all actually
intriguing even though I know Kurt Russell's
character does not end up with this doctor
lady I I'm still like what happened here I want
to know what happened here how did Monarch come
to be how did Lee Shaw go from respected revered
supposed to be the main man in charge of Monarch
the to suddenly getting pushed down the ranks uh
demoted what like what became of them like I am
actually every time we cut back to them I want to
know what happened even though we know the outcome
does not end in their favor I really I really am
there going like God let me and I feel like they
Advance the story I feel like we actually progress
and uh the visuals there I I think just because of
50s aesthetic they when you apply a little bit of
a Sheen over some familiar settings it is is just
automatically more intriguing and more Dynamic
right away uh yeah so I I really love everything
they do there and and the chemistry between the
three even the uh romantic uh what's it love
triangle even the love triangle uh aspects of it
which is such a Trope in television uh it's still
even here like how did Randa just get on board
with like yeah I can see that my buddy's kind
of in love with her I'm the Third Wheel here then
eventually he's like I'm marry you or I'm going
to pregnant you or whatever it happens I forget I
forget what they D I can't tell yeah if he's just
like you they're together in the first episode
when they goow to the flashback right yeah they're
a couple yeah and they have a kid together yeah
and so part of me I don't know maybe he is just
so much like yeah I really am just married to my
uh my work here and I'm really just this is what
enchants my life so if you guys are interested in
love you should do that I don't know I don't know
what to think about that um maybe he Rand falls
in love with her eventually well yeah I guess I
don't know it it they the way not maybe yeah the
way they've played the character just seems like
is not really that it it on one hand feels like
he suspects them but love but he cares about Lee
and and you know feels like they're friends and
Lee is probably mostly just fixated on he doesn't
suspect them he plat out says what's worse than
being a third wheel a fourth wheel he knows he's
third Wheeling the situation yeah I guess so so
like I don't know yeah maybe this maybe what we
saw here in this episode will lead to the rift
or I don't know like it is I am a little question
about like the trajectory and and bullet points
of their dynamic because at the moment he does
just seem like oh yeah well you guys are really
hitting it off so you do your thing because I'm
interested in this gamma Dinner Bell you know yeah
and and uh well it seems like what's what's her
name good Japanese woman yes yeah one of the good
ones one of the good ones one of the good ones
Japanese woman uh okay that's what the show told
me to feel about her yes and K well it seems like
K and Shaw they they couldn't be together like no
I mean their their love seems quite rather doomed
yeah but beyond it's not just like oh we didn't
get along or some [__] it's because of the
positions that they hold and goals and motivations
that interfere yeah and a whole bunch of things
that that get in the way that would prevent
them from being together to the things that
she's bringing up in this episode of uh this
would cause a rift between us and there's no
way we can actually make this work yeah so that's
your position and mine are kind of antithetical
yeah so him showing up is the thing that that's
why she's not like happy to see him when he shows
up yeah of course because he should be staying
behind and doing his part and then because he
went over there it led a little bit more to their
downfall yeah the love is is kind of directly in
obstacle to Monarch forming the right way that's
what happens to Asian fetishes man they get in
the way that's right just ask my dad oh boy look
out now um um but yeah I I I I don't know yeah I
would agree even though that stuff is is also
pretty familiar territory to tread yeah I feel
like they the acting is just so much better and
the writing better better the writing is better
the production designs and the production values
coales much better on that timeline because when
we cut back to the present especially when we
were in the desert throughout a lot of that uh
I I could really feel when we were switching
back in force between okay this is on location
but this is on a volume or some kind of green
screen and and they're in these pristine what
look like freshly purchased costume clothes uh
that are like even after like avalanching down
a hill you know in the desert you know are only
vaguely kind of dusted up afterwards they have
these like pristine designer sunglasses and
and I don't know yeah it like it's so weird
it feels like two different sets of writers are
writing these different I guess which is like a
fun experiment but also yeah you get back to the
present and again this episode I was like no I'm
going to give the benefit of the doubt I really
liked May's confession scene for instance um but
there is something just kind of frustrating and
a little Annoying about the way that they're the
most the character I like the most on the present
day timeline is is uh the one they call Madame
wazelle or whatever she comes the the the Monarch
op who's you know uh you know what's her name from
the MCU John no keep explaining because I clearly
don't know who you're talking about she's she's my
favorite on she's the most actualized character to
me on the current timeline and maybe it's because
she's mysterious and she don't say much but like
I don't know she's got a lot of presence and I
believe her in ways where the rest of them feel
detached and even Kurt Russell still while he
had more to do here I'm like I still feel like
they just kind of plopped you in and we're just
like hey man do your thing you know yeah he was a
little more intense this time and the scene with
her I thought you know that exchange with the
French and her clearing out the van and him you
know like kind of sizing up the situation with
her I thought that was good you know and uh and
then we get dude it's the three leads suck I got
to tell you man they are keep trying to like are
not good characters hate to break it to everyone
but I was bad for those actors I was on board for
for that at first Kate I thought was great the
first episode um but the more we spend time with
these characters the more I'm just like God when
you guys speak I check out like the dialogue for I
force myself to pay attention the second you guys
start talking I'm like oh man just too much damage
has been done yes I don't even know if I can warm
up to you guys now I I want them just start slice
of lifing them because I'm just like anything
just like don't give them something different
to say give them something completely unrelated
to talk about for like a hot minute like I loved
doing the the the ball thing at the beginning cuz
we're doing Exposition but we're also like fading
in and out of like human moments which just don't
seem to exist at all on the on the modern timeline
looking for my dad well I I I just think they
they make them all say the same it's just the
same line same lines and hammering the same go
kind of delivery every freaking every time my
God there's no range always so posed and they're
always so pristine like let them be a little bit
like their actual out ruffing it traversing the
world now in a desert after been like kataro just
seems so like lifeless they just all seem like
they're along for this whes like they're the same
twoo performances throughout the entire show and
may other than the one time she's like lamenting
her like the whole thing she did is just dry it it
they're the they are the three most boring leads
you could put in your show when you're like we're
going to make our human characters interesting
and they're always aggravated with each other
that makes abrasive to watch they're so boring
but everything else is actually intriguing other
than I this this episode only um made that Crystal
to me was we didn't really give them that much
dialogue we didn't really give them that much
time everyone else did and I was like this is the
best episode what was was different other than
you know Focus oh we didn't really focus on them
yeah they only kind of hearkened back when there
was like a mirror in the action to to get back to
or something and when we did focus on them they
had the same same [__] they say all the time and
when they were about to run off into the desert at
the very end and Kate is like brimming you she's
like she has like some Spirit about her she's
like almost excited she's like no no we're good
come on was like oh maybe this will be a splash
of color and then we immediately the moment was
too predict immediately had to reset that it felt
like such a scene like like like such a okay play
this H like it was so obvious that okay well she's
doing this now because some information getting
dealt through away then we're right back to the
same tone we're used to with her character
guitar just being like so aggravating May
Kate Godzilla and even their dad is looking
for Dad Dad is is even getting on my nerves
oh he's annoying too yeah dude no they're all
very annoying and and and I I I think we've
spent five episodes trying to as much as we've
complained we've tried to deconstruct like but
what are they going for and I want to see what
yeah and but I got to tell you man six episodes
in they are I should like something about any
of these people the best people on the modern
timeline remain Tim Madame wazelle and the Annie
McDow lady who like the least focused on well they
even get the guy the I forget his name but
the doctor character and the past oh Suzuki
great great breath of fresh air excellent yeah
breath of fresh air uh again everyone in the past
intrig like the military people feel more evil and
menacing than you're menacing Monarch characters
and like you're you're menacing military people
in the past feel more menacing than your modern
day modern characters it's so weird cuz they're
not writing extraordinarily more complex stuff
for the past characters to deal with they're just
mixing them together in something that feels more
like actual life and the visuals are are solid I
I I think this is the first time in the monster
verse could be wrong but I feel like it's correct
like we're so used to seeing Godzilla and City
Landscapes usually in wet yeah it's raining and uh
that is wet sure raining involved droplets maybe a
wave who knows wet Joe yeah water yeah wet that's
wet but this is the first time I think we've seen
him in like just the driest of Landscapes which
I thought was cool uh to see mhm just oh my God
these character I'm sorry I I try to move past
it but I can they're just so stupid like it's
so weird this the the only reason they found their
dad was following Shaw was following Kurt Russell
yeah and then they see God like right face to face
she has this moment where she's like he looked at
me and he's like yeah gotta go find my dad my dad
uh we're g to go for own like where are you going
to go where are you going to go what are you going
to do alone what are you doing especially now that
she sold you out I mean you like you you had to
get to that point to find it out but also they're
still heading you know 10 clicks that way to go
back before dinner so like what are you going
to yeah what do you expect to I don't know maybe
that'll open up a new passage of the show where
they can find some new character that'll that'll
enchant this timeline but uh canaro is definitely
the worst of them though I I would if I were to
rank that canaro is the worst he's every line they
give him is like he says it with the same delivery
yes every single time like there's there's there's
a difference between like subtle and just no
effort like being put in to give him stuff I
I don't I just can't handle chilling they they
undercut everything Kate does by making her look
like a supermodel all the time instead of just
like trusting that she's beautiful and letting her
be in costume and then uh ciry Clemens is is like
in a drama is trying to be in a drama yeah none
of them match what kind of thing they're trying
to be in and and it just doesn't feel like the
script cares I don't know so weird it doesn't feel
like the script cares at all to give in that dance
scene we had that little interlude where they have
the the like the sound Fades out and we're in an
intimate moment and it's just sensory and I'm like
you could find some weird way of doing that the
closest we've ever gotten on this modern timeline
is when they're singing in the wreck Zone in the
last episode which was like fine that's nice you
know but it also seemed like a stupid moment for
yeah I know was shoehorned in there also felt like
what are you doing you guys know there's a bunch
of soldiers out here yeah going to hunt down you
undercut by like carelessness of writing or or
you know it's or or the they could have even play
I don't know they could have played that in a way
where it's like he's trying to keep quiet but
he's also trying to you know uh uh break down
her defenses and and you know warm her up and and
yeah I don't know it just seems like I I don't I
don't understand how this happens because if they
do have two teams riding both timelines it feels
like there's no communication between them and I
feel like somebody in assembling these episodes
would have to be like hey we should probably get
on the same page here I mean this was my I still
think this was probably their best episode they've
done because of all the reasons we said because
like the like the things we have complained about
the most are barely the runtime of the episode
and all the highlights of the episode are the
majority of the runtime so I totally like even
like Bill Randa in the past I think is a very fun
charismatic character love I think k is a really
compelling character as well great presence um
and good they all have chemistry like like a like
Asian female scientist at at the at a time where
it's like wow that's those are not just Asian
Japanese female SCI at a time where like being
any of those as a scientist is not like not not
a popular thing like a very intriguing character
um with a lot of depth to her and and then uh yeah
Kurt Russell scenes where he's not with the main
casted characters are great and and yeah there was
like some actual moments of suspense and some cool
and some like mon both moments of Godzilla both
coming out of the water and even the debate they
have in the past of of I thought I think that's
such an interesting debate like they think they
killed Godzilla they discover he's alive and and
what do we do now what do we do and then tell
the world frustration of the conversation like
I love that that little transa that little um
yeah transaction of dialogue between for like
like maybe just a page is worth of dialogue yeah
of we we used America's most deadly weapon against
it and we couldn't do it and then what are they
going to do then sh they're going to build an even
greater weapon and if that doesn't work they'll
build a greater one if it's not working on them
they're going to test it on I was like damn
that is that's a really great Point like what
what do you do that is so much more ining more
like anything else that yeah well and on top of
that and then it leads into like a a detriment for
them right away you know yeah absolutely and that
plays into the greater Stakes that he talks about
with Pucket about like it's about the choice that
you make and if you make the right choice you can
run the organization the way that you see fit and
you know then he goes out for love but then they
find this discovery this is a big deal like it
all mashes together in a way that actually feels
alive and compelling absolutely yeah so um and
now the bad guys are taking over and we're going
to going to see the soul yeah I I like the also
the portrayal the fight for the soul of Monarch
and personifying that in these characters Yeah
man so there's a lot of there's a lot of really
good stuff in here yeah um that is that you just
can't help but get frustrated when you're like
okay Su is the the problem is the [__] three
leads they got that they they're just not written
I I don't they're just not they're not ritten well
and and I'm like I I can't even tell you if the
actors are good or not I know because I'm like
is it the actors I don't think so because the
freaking writing of them is the same dialogue
yeah and it doesn't I don't know it's the one
part of the show where when I'm watching it
the movie Magic comes apart and I don't feel like
anyone's direct being directed by anybody like the
three leads and Kurt Russell when he's with the
leads don't feel like anyone's directing them it
feels like it's just kind of up to them to make
a scene happen and I don't know why I'm getting
that impression but yeah and then you know I'm
starting to notice like oh here are the effects
and there are the wardrobes and and yeah that's
these are just all the wrong problems to have
but hey that's where we're at people um what did
you think about this episode leave your thoughts
down below um we you only got a couple more left
how many got six we got four left jeez hey these
leads could still improve they can still give us
a compelling emotional thread there's still time
to rewrite the Sho there's still hey you can
always kill them all they have like she might
have a a psychic link with Godzilla that that
could be cool or I'm afraid Godzilla is going
to be like no I should have crushed you I'm sorry
yeah I don't waste these Bonds on just anybody 30
seconds later she moves on yeah she's just like
got to get out of here like oh my God what a
great moment you have with this character to like
her trauma is so rooted in in and like she's got
a lot of trauma but man she had the devastation
of everything that happened her she was there on
the grounds for gday she was there and she comes
face to face with the monster and and 30 seconds
later it's just like I'm going to go find my
dad well we don't even in that sequence bad
that sequence is it's the time where you would
absolutely want to throw in some of those PTSD
flourishes and reallya yeah it's the time Jesus
watched it like oh God and it just plays like a
regular action scene and then she gallivant off
10 clicks that way yeah so weird oh my God and
it just feels like then the PTSD is just a device
so that in the Godzilla list episodes they can be
like well here's a justification for why we
can show godzill [__] God they really let
me down here man it's great I love the show it's
great uh I I still look forward to watching still
the still the best episode still the best still
the best episode I still liked it lot of I still
like this one over like uh like definitely like a
landslide over to the like side of Yes Man the the
the parts that don't work like oh did they cast
a shadow hey we got we got two episodes 100% in
the present last couple then hopefully next two
will be 100% in the past man we can do that for
a while and then tie it all around at the end
all right guys well leave your thoughts down
below pick a name John any name guo Galindo
John went with the first person the one we
don't know guo gindo guo Galindo you are the
first patron of the day shout out that we are
doing you know what Santa's giving you this
year for Christmas the first shout out at the
real rejects of December 20123 Good Golly and
it's a Greg shout out why because you kicked
it off I mean I'm here too but your name begins
with G gto's names begin with G there's so many
G's we're doing a classic here go to chat G
no what gole we can use our own brains okay
okay my brain's been corrupted by this process I
can't think for myself any longer I need you and
I need G stands for good boy you stands for
under my sheets with me I stands for I like
to kick men in the balls and it turns me on T
stands for turned on by you gito oh St for oh
that hurts when you kick me in the balls ooh
are we going full name or just sure why not
it's Christmas we'll see how this goes St for
go stop kicking me in the balls hey STS for try
the ass now L stands for uh Licking which is
what you're giving me I stands for I like to
eats pickles n stands for nachos cuz everyone
loves nachos d stands for dang dog digity with
the did oh stands for uh what you give each and
every one of us when we think of you guo thank
you so much for being part of our patreon page
you super sexy reject you we love [Music] you